from Koi Revelations about the
soundtrack to why Ariel's casting caused
such an uproar here's everything you
need to know to Dive Into 2023's The
Little Mermaid
there have been many incarnations of The
Little Mermaid over the years from the
mature original story written by Hans
Christian Anderson to Disney's more
upbeat interpretation so there are
clearly many different directions the
plot of the new film could go however
judging by lin-manuel Miranda's
involvement it's safe to say that the
newest version of The Little Mermaid
will stick close to the original 1989
animated film plot details have yet to
be revealed but Miranda has given some
interesting tidbits about the upcoming
movie and variety's awards circuit
podcast the Tony award winner indicated
that the plot is largely focused on
Ariel trading her voice for a pair of
legs he told the podcast we wrote some
music for her time on land she
experiences a lot of Firsts as someone
with legs for the first time so he got
to lean into all of that musically
in terms of who will be starring in The
Little Mermaid the film struck gold
Ariel will be portrayed by Grammy winner
Hallie Bailey who is part of the duo
Chloe and Halle Bailey has exploded in
recent years for both her singing and
her acting in addition to her new role
as Ariel Vanity Fair announced she has
also joined the big screen adaptation of
the Broadway production of The Color
Purple in an interview with variety
Bailey had this to say about playing
Ariel I want the little girl in me and
the little girls just like me who are
watching to know that they are special
and that they should be a princess in
every single way there's no reason that
they shouldn't be so I'm just grateful
that I've been able to take the essence
of me and kind of mix the two bayley
will not be the only notable actor in
the film however other cast members
include Javier Bardem as King Triton
Melissa McCarthy as Ursula David Diggs
as Sebastian and Aquafina as scuttle
like many highly anticipated films of
the past few years The Little Mermaid
had some obstacles along the way casting
began in 2019 with the film going into
production the following year then in
2020 Entertainment Weekly reported that
The Little Mermaid was one of many films
whose Productions were suddenly halted
due to the covid-19 pandemic shangshi
and the legend of the ten Rings
nightmare alley and the last duel were
also impacted by the pandemic luckily
all of these films have been released
and it looks as if the Little Mermaid
will be the next to hit theaters the
film's release date is May 26 2023
wherever lin-manuel Miranda goes it
seems that director Rob Marshall follows
or maybe it's the other way around the
two collaborated on the 2018 sequel Mary
Poppins returns with Miranda playing the
part of Jack now the two are
collaborating once again in The Little
Mermaid with martial directing and
Miranda producing but Marshall's
connection to Miranda isn't the only
thing the director has going for him the
filmmaker has plenty of experience
making musicals having previously
directed into the woods nine and most
significantly Chicago full of dazzling
visuals and set pieces and starring both
Catherine Zeta Jones and Renee Zellweger
Chicago swept the 2003 Oscars becoming a
definitive film for Rob Marshall so
after proving himself as an accomplished
musical director there's no telling what
Rob Marshall will bring to The Little
Mermaid he's a human you're a mermaid
that doesn't make us enemies
film adaptations of The Little Mermaid
began with Disney's celebrated 1989
animated classic but that's not the only
Little Mermaid film out there so if
you're in a nostalgic kind of mood you
may want to peruse the rest of the
catalog in 2000 Disney released a sequel
The Little Mermaid 2 returned to the Sea
the animated film revolves around Ariel
and Eric's daughter Melody who comes to
terms with her mermaid Heritage other
films in The Little Mermaid Universe
include the little mermaid Ariel's
Beginning which is a prequel to The
Original film and for those who don't
know all the words to the songs they can
always watch The Little Mermaid
sing-along for those wanting a
live-action version of the film there's
that too released in 2019 The Little
Mermaid live was a Stage production
filmed for ABC and later televised on
the Network stars Queen Latifah and John
Stamos brought some Prestige to the
production but not many were impressed
The Little Mermaid live earned a dismal
36 critic score on Rotten Tomatoes still
if you're a die-hard fan of The Little
Mermaid then you'll be happy to know
that all of these film are available to
stream on Disney Plus
so here's the Shocker even though the
Little Mermaid takes place Beneath the
Sea the live-action remake wasn't filmed
at the bottom of the ocean weird right
instead production for the 2023 remake
began in London in 2020. principal
photography took place at the famed
Pinewood Studios in England which is
best known as the shooting location for
many of the James Bond movies but
Pinewood wasn't the only location on
Disney's radar in 2021 The Little
Mermaid moved its production to Sardinia
Italy where they shot in the village of
Santa Teresa de galura
a big challenge for The Little Mermaid
was how to set entire dialogue heavy
scenes underwater while filming them on
land director Rob Marshall told the wrap
in February of 2023 The Little Mermaid
is the most challenging film I've ever
done I don't think anybody's ever done
an underwater musical before Marshall
went on to say we were using complicated
cutting-edge techniques to make this
work every single moment had to be
choreographed in advance so that we
could have a flow to the whole piece
it's crazy the apparatuses we worked
with from wires to things called tuning
Forks to teeter-totters that said many
of the actors still had to be in water
for long stretches of time while filming
their scenes while speaking to Variety
in early 2023 Hallie Bailey estimated
that she spent upwards of 13 hours a day
in water in some cases she went on to
add I pushed myself as far as I've ever
pushed myself in life I feel like the
message from Ariel was to know that
you've always had it in you
like most Disney movies The Animated
Little Mermaid has several hit songs
that have withstood the test of time
take Ariel's part of your world for
instance the song is an empowering
classic that quickly became the
signature tune of Jody Benson who voiced
Ariel in the original film meanwhile
Poor Unfortunate Souls is a fun and
villainous tune kiss the girl is a
romantic Calypso and Under the Sea ranks
among the most famous Disney songs of
all time under the sea was the number
for me needless to say music is key to
the Little Mermaid not long after the
Remake was announced news broke that
Alan Menken the co-writer of the
original soundtrack would be returning
mengan was hired to assist lin-manuel
Miranda in writing new songs and lyrics
for the Remake it was also confirmed
that many of the tracks from the
animated film would return for the new
film in talking with Vanity Fair Menken
explained that even though popular
tracks like Kiss the Girl and Poor
Unfortunate Souls are revered some of
the lyrics will be changed to make the
songs more accessible to Modern
sensibilities while referring to kiss
the girl mengan told vanity Fair people
have gotten very sensitive about the
idea that Prince Eric would in any way
force himself on Ariel he added that
Ursula's song was likewise reworked to
avoid bad messaging even though Ursula
is clearly manipulating her to give up
her voice as menkin noted to Vanity Fair
after Melissa McCarthy and Aquafina were
announced as cast members of The Little
Mermaid fans anxiously awaited an
announcement of who would play Ariel
though there were initially some rumors
that Zendaya would be starring in the
role they proved to be just that rumors
when it was later announced that Halle
Bailey would be taking on the part
people online voiced their displeasure
their complaint was that by casting
bayley the look of Ariel would change in
a statement published by variety
director Rob Marshall said this about
Bailey's casting after an extensive
search it was abundantly clear that
tally possesses that rare combination of
spirit heart youth innocence and
substance plus a glorious singing voice
all intrinsic qualities necessary to
play this iconic role in the age of the
internet it isn't too hard to find
someone outraged online so there's
little surprise that some took umbrage
at the film's perceived race swapping
detractors cited the European location
of Denmark in the original Hans
Christian Anderson fairy tale as well as
Ariel's appearance in the animated film
as reasons she should look similar to
the 1989 film still others just disliked
the idea of a remake in general getting
to kind of put my own take on Ariel is a
beautiful thing likewise the casting of
McCarthy as Ursula was met with some
criticism in the original film the
character of Ursula had clear drag queen
influences as the character was based on
Divine a recurring actor in several of
director John Waters films so many
assumed that a drag queen would be cast
in the role
with all the changes being made to Ariel
and her Supporting Cast it would be
surprising If Prince Eric was left
completely Untouched by director Rob
Marshall and his crew when speaking
about Ariel's human Dreamboat martial
confirmed that Eric too would be
undergoing some changes the director
told Entertainment Weekly the role of
Eric in the animated film I'm sure the
original creators would agree with this
it's a wooden classic Prince character
with not a lot going on in the remake
this new version of Prince Eric played
by a dog's way home actor Jonah Howard
King is a bit more four-dimensional as
the Director told total film magazine
Marshall also added that the updated
Prince Eric has a story similar to Ariel
and that he wants more out of life
Marshall told Entertainment Weekly these
two Kindred Spirits find each other and
really Teach the World about prejudice
and about breaking down barriers and
walls between these two worlds in the
1989 feature the Wayward Prince doesn't
have a lot going on outside of trying to
find and marry the woman who saved his
life that said it remains to be seen
just how different Eric will be and I
can't wait for people to see it there
have been many live-action remakes of
iconic Disney titles in recent years
this could mean one of two things either
the studio is out of ideas or they're
giving the audience more of what it
wants still with many of these
live-action remakes finding success
there's always speculation about which
animated Classics should get the
live-action treatment next currently
Disney has a few other musical features
that are in various stages of
development the first of these is a mark
Webb directed Snow White from a
screenplay by Academy Award nominee
Greta Gerwig guy Richie is also
reportedly working on a remake of the
1997 animated film Hercules an updated
version of the Hunchback of Notre Dame
is also in development even Lilo and
Stitch is getting the live action
treatment in addition to remakes of
beloved animated films Disney is also
working on producing sequels to many of
their newly minted features the studio
plans to release a sequel to the 2019
version of Aladdin a new Jungle Book and
a prequel called Mufasa The Lion King
needless to say the iconic Studio has
clearly doubled down on the ring make
game